welcome to this video playing you belong
hmm you be lunch jubilant whatever
there's no name no not GM let's see get
a sloth defense yeah something like a
sloth maybe he will delay deform ok try
to get in Bishop f5 anyway or maybe i
can i can play this this first
yeah there are also ideas like later
Bishop to g4 maybe Bishop g4 here age
three I can exchange play six a very
solid structure
that's a good good defensive set up not
very active but also very sound sound
position or interesting yeah let's look
at this okay I'd like to get an e5
obvious level so let's see
is 698 and since things like that I
wonder I can also take on see form
that's not totally off the 95 like 96 95
it's also very very solid maybe with his
slightly weakened King scientist could
be an IDM the knight on d5 is quite a
nice piece that is not easily easily
expelled as he forward we can spawn
structure yeah too much okay just here
maybe that I can get in create form and
I will play this be five and then things
I could yeah I could play b5 myself and
then a five just why not actually see
six is a week but is this so important
though the then general structure looks
very good i also have rook a six to
cover c6 when the knight on d5 is really
great you can never play your form
all right that's okay but really looks
okay for black okay here means I better
for black not just equal maybe I'm too
optimistic but it looks very nice now I
can take maybe look a 40 k 8 Bishop f8
looking at the people on why he takes
rook takes then the a3 pawn is the
weakness yeah covering this Bishop evade
the background clocks a bit weak I hope
there is no tactic no but I don't think
so really does not look like there
should be a tactic but something crazy
lucky for and if I ever that's the only
thing that worries me something
something violent happening if I get
somewhat to some more through some moves
more in the bishop f8 in it it starts to
get very depressing for white
okay there must be some some very direct
justification for that otherwise he is
just wicked too sir his King side
terribly okay is going for the counter
play down take a couple of times he will
take c6 but then I have the check ham
and that the end rotate to one this is
quite good he has the check the only
eight that's not that's not good so
should i start with the checks IAM tags
tags he has a ton of checks with Queenie
aid at the end that'sthat's really not
not good
what about this look a for loop c 6-r
oopsy form keeping trying to keep the
initiative let's do that but that's
could be good Brooks is six loops you
form now that that that that could be a
good idea Brooksie form is an
interesting threat gem yeah look a six I
takes it too and then the check will win
I hope I believe so we must do that and
this is nice now I gave half the seaport
and I have still ideas to get it back or
play rugby 822 rook b6 to be three ok I
can go here I will just play against
against the Queen site IAM trying to to
get the pawn now
okay it's not so good to exchange the
bed bishop but ok need to make progress
start with the check here take it queen
of 3 or C 3 I can take it place III
that'sthat's good time go get the pawn
to see to check yeah he's having this
counter play with Queen Queen e5
trying to gain some room here for the
king so that i can do to g6 maybe after
check check
I don't see a way forward Tim
unfortunately really doing maybe with G
form
maybe I can promote and then g4s this
may be some way to attack him probably
not yeah maybe still try that it's
interesting I can just go to edge to
check I forgot about this check check
check check check check how can I he's
on minus already how can i fulfill on
time sorry he has overstepped the time
already he's on minus why is he not
losing on time I am what hey I'm sorry
what is this I was he was on minus
already my clock wasn't even ticking
anymore ah come on come on check check
ok ok that's really high especially
after the cause of the game way was
completely outplayed and this was really
good I mean I'm really satisfied here
this this looked like a good game I
always was in control him check and yeah
I fail to find the right continuation
that that's clear i should i should win
him like just simply on position but ok
it's always minus free i didn't i didn't
manage to to to find it at the end this
was a gamble with a couple of seconds on
the check check check he had already
always stepped the time he is on 0 why
is it not lost yeah come on
ah let's stop this recording him